the last time that we spoke me and you
talked about population Decline and the
Census Bureau just released today
predicting that the US population will
decline for the first time ever by the
year 201100 after peaking in 2080 so
their estimates showed that the US
population which is about 333 million at
the moment it's expected to reach 370 by
2080 but will be back down to 366 by
2100 and even immigration can't offset
this birth rate
decline over the last two years do you
think things have got better or worse
than you anticipated from birth rate and
marriage rate standpoint I think they're
probably still getting
worse uh and I think
musk musk is one of the few people Elon
Musk is one of the in case anybody was
wondering um he's one of the few people
who who's called out the danger of you
know a one child policy or the idea that
we should decrease the population I
mean things that don't grow die but they
die for all sorts of reasons and we
could we could tie this back to Identity
you know what's my identity I could say
well it's how I feel about myself that's
that's the line that's used everywhere
now you don't get to tell me who I am I
know who I am I can I'm who I feel I am
well first of all I don't even know what
you mean by feel like what the hell what
does that mean you're your emotional
state at the moment and you can just
impose that on everybody that's your
theory is it that's the theory of a
2-year-old literally that's a very bad
Theory
well where could your identity be other
than that well one of my identities when
I taught at Harvard was Professor
obviously and that was a good identity
but you know that wasn't exactly it
wasn't something I was carrying around
in my head it was a pattern of
relationship that I had with a whole
bunch of people all my students
right it wasn't inside my head now there
was a concordance between my
representation of myself and how I was
acting in the world and that concordance
was the health it wasn't what I thought
of myself you
like part of the reason that you can
take some let's call it gratification
from being a successful podcaster is
that you're actually a successful
podcaster it's not in your head it's in
one .5 million subscribers it's how many
podcasts have you done 700 okay so it's
in 700 podcasts it's not something
you're carrying around in your head do
you remember I loved the 42 Rules that
created the 24 that you ended up coming
up with but there's one that you didn't
use uh if you have to choose be the one
who does things right not the one who is
seen to do things exactly absolutely I
love that rule oh yeah that's a great
rule that's a great rule yeah well the
thing is is that you can do almost
anything you want want if you're willing
to take responsibility for it if you
don't want credit one of the most
effective political maneuver I've ever
seen woman who's she's so brilliant I
won't tell you who she is but she's so
sharp she's so brilliant and she told me
the last time I saw her she's had her
finger in pies for like 30 years popping
up in places you'd never expect I
thought I asked her it's like how the
hell did you pull this off and she said
oh I decided 30 years ago that I could
do whatever I wanted if I didn't want
credit and so that's exactly what she's
done and she's had a stellar career
stellar and I've worked with other
people who've done the same thing it's
very interesting it's very interesting
thing to realize you might say well why
would I want the responsibility without
the glory it's like hey do you want the
glory are you so sure that that wouldn't
just get in your way you know there's
something to be said for anonymity and
second maybe you want the responsibility
because that's the adventure you
actually get to do the thing that
someone else just wants to take credit
for well maybe doing the thing is plenty
of reward in and of
itself with regard to
Identity you know when when I was a
professor I was also a husband and I was
also a father well those were identities
but they weren't in my head they were
embedded in the relationship I had with
my kids and that was a meaningful
relationship embedded in the
relationship I had with my wife you
can't be you know it's almost heretical
to say this in the modern
world you can't be isolated
alone without responsibility and
pursuing your hedonistic
nonsense and not be insane and miserable
those are all the same thing right and
so you know it's got to the point i'
I've said things that have made me
somewhat unpopular like it's very
difficult for people to mature until
they have a
child you find a huge part of what you
are in that relationship it makes you
responsible makes you grow up it gives
you the opportunity to Mentor someone
you have someone around who's more
important than you well that's part of
being mentally healthy it's a huge part
of it this is this Enterprise that I put
together in London help put together
Alliance for responsible citizenship
we're trying to put forward a model of
governance it's called subsidiary model
and the idea is
that people have multiple social roles
that scale
no there's you should take care of
yourself integrate yourself which means
you can conduct yourself properly across
the medium to long run your self-
sustaining then you can maybe extend
that to your partner and then to your
family and then to your local community
and then to broader communities as you
become more and more competent and able
to take on that
responsibility that's the alternative to
isolated hedonic slavery you slave to
your own whims and it's the alternative
to tyranny because if you take on all
that responsibility you don't have any
need for someone to govern you and so
that's another example of
how I blamed it on the therapists a
little bit I called them liberal
Protestant
secularists and that's
because they think about the locus of
the psyche as
interior subjective that's what a
liberal would do
it's just not accurate that isn't that
isn't the way the psyche works it's not
in your head you know it's it's in your
head and in the world at the same time
it's truly the case that your sanity is
the
concordance between you as an individual
and the world that's the sanity it's not
the proper structuring of your psyche or
your brain for that matter inside your
skull you're distributed out into the
world and you should be and that's you
want to be that's where the adventure is
you want to be
solipsistic a solipsistic porn
masturbator Jesus it's no wonder you be
aimless and miserable well God it's so
pathetic why am I so unhappy it's
because you think about yourself no you
think about the lowest impulses in
yourself all the time that's why you're
miserable we'll get back to talking to
Jordan in minute but first I need to
tell you about element I've used element
every single morning for over 3 years
now it is the way I start every single
day it tastes fantastic it optimizes my
hydration helps to regulate my appetite
and it improves my brain health element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium pottassium and magnesium
best of all they've got a brand new
chocolate caramel flavor which you can
have hot hot element I hear you say what
sort of hydration blasphemy is this but
no it tastes fantastic and on cold
mornings it's perfect there is is a nobs
no questions asked refund policy so you
can buy it and try it completely
risk-free and if you do not like it for
any reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the Box I've used this every single
morning for as long as I can remember
and that orange flavor is phenomenal
plus that chocolate caramel is available
right now if you go to the link in the
show notes below or head to drink LM
nt.com slod wisdom for a free sample
pack of all eight flavors with your
first box that's drink LM nt.com /
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Jordan you will love the over three-hour
long podcast episode which is available
right here go
on give it a tap